we get sent for game one of three over
the weekend the razor in arlington to
take on
the rangers the rays have been to that
ballpark before the last time they were
there they lost to the dodgers in the
world series of 2020
and now they're there during the regular
season of 2021 kyle gibson takes to the
mound today coming off as stand on the
injured list but he has been the best
starter for the rangers this year
gibson's 2-2 and he strikes out loud
that's how we get started tonight
got him out of good change up throwing a
hard sinker early
comes back with something a little bit
different the change up and
by the swing you can see how far out in
front of it two up two down for joey
wendell
and the lefty swings and rolls one out
to second solak charges has it flips to
first a one two three
inning for kyle benjamin gibson josh
fleming on the mound today for the raise
after
his performance against the philadelphia
phillies in which he picked up the win
he has four consecutive wins
two down for chris davis there's a swing
in the ground ball to short
throw us offline a little bit but yandy
comes off the bag to apply the tag
and that will retire the side so three
up three now and go to rangers come with
one there's gandhi diaz
hitting 246 but without a home run looks
at the 1-0 and grounds it back up toward
the middle and end this center field
for a base hit so yandy picks up the
first race hit kiramire hitting 216.
diaz running there's a ground ball right
side of the infield
sliding stopped by solac and he takes
care of kier meyer
fairly well hit nice play to the left by
nick zolok
taylor walls who has not proven to be a
great hitter yet
and he takes this one rolls it sharply
down to first
nate lowe goes to the bag ahead of him
and that will in the inning going to the
bottom of the second we're still
scoreless
one gone for former raised minor leaguer
nick solar there's a bouncing ball on
the right side that's through a base hit
and solace fought one off the other way
he's the first rangers base runner two
outs here's culberson the pitch
on its way here's a swing of the ground
ball left side shortstop walls has it
it's only played at first
and it's in plenty of time and that will
retire the side
routine switch hitting catcher francisco
mejia leads off
and that's going to be strike three call
top of the zone
what a smart pitch by kyle gibson
recognizing francisco mejia kept going
down to try to get under the baseball he
elevates
well two up two down both these pitchers
have moved quickly
through the respective lineups and
delivers and this pitch is lifted very
high into the air
out into shallow center back pedaling as
kiner falloffa
and the ranger shortstop makes the one
hand grab to retire lau one
two three go the raise we played two and
a half at arlington for no official time
at beth therefore trevino who moves
calhoun
into scoring position and now here comes
isaiah keiner falefa
this one rifled down to third base
wendell gets in a race to third
and for a moment there i think lost his
senses he had the outage first
instead he wanted to get calhoun yeah i
think wendell caught the runner out of
the corner of his eye
and thought it was going to be an easy
tag play at third base first and third
for adolesce garcia has been their best
power hitter
garcia goes after the first pitch
wendell goes to second one the relay
not in time first run of the game is in
and the rangers have it tonight
calhoun scores in third on the fielder's
choice and it's one nothing
looks like the rays we're asking to
challenge the play
my guess is that they're looking at the
sliding second base here
to make sure that conor felefer stayed
within the the guideline
yeah so it is fine the slide was fine
so that will be your first texas rangers
run well good start so far
for gibson here's randy rosarina leading
off the fourth
swing and a miss and rosa reina he's
carved up in that effect
that's what kyle has done all season the
combination of his pitches
just bewilders the hitter that is hit
number two against
kyle gibson wendell at first here with
one out now for austin meadows
got him at first wendell was leaning
just a bit towards second
and you could tell that little
hesitation that gibson had finally
gotten it
that pickoff is the second out of the
inning yeah that's a quick move to first
base and an accurate throw
and a swing and a miss on the very next
pitch a strikeout of meadows and gibson
with another scoreless half inning
couple of singles and the rangers have
minutes first and second with nobody out
now
for nate lowe this one out towards
center field
gets down base hit gallow around third
he heads to the plate he'll score
without a throw
rbi single by nate lowe and the rangers
have a two nothing lead
three singles great josh fleming and the
first offering here to culberson is a
safety squeeze
bunted back to fleming his only play to
first culverson's out but solak scores
it's three nothing texas the first and
third
squeeze bunt but not a suicide squeeze
we actually saw madden put it on with
the angels earlier this year it's the
first time the rangers
have executed that play a runner-up
second one out but two runs home here
for texas
this ball was hit back up the middle
past walls and into center
rounding third is low here comes the
throw from tier meyer
it's not in time going to second calhoun
the throw there
is in time the tag applied by lao but
it's an rbi
single for willie calhoun as nate lowe
scores a tough night as far as command
goes
and he's hit the middle of the plate the
rangers have had good swings at him
strong throw from kier but offline a
little bit
and let's see if we can tell whether
he's out or safe
sure looks safe to me rangers eight for
18 on challenges and you can make it
nine
for 19. calhoun is safe so two down in
the inning top of the order now isaiah
keiner philippa
and a line drive into the left one hop
to meadows
he's gonna take it to the plate and the
throw is gonna be
in time as meadows cuts down calhoun
trying to score watch his throw this may
be the best so i've ever seen him make
step throw power through the ball stays
true there's no tail it's not up the
line
it is right on the money and there are
two away
with the rangers leading four to nothing
here joey gallo
coming to the plate he has grounded the
short and ignited the three-run rally
last inning
gallow hits this ball well deep out to
center field
it's gone tenth of the year for joey
and he makes it a five-nothing rangers
lead there's a pitch
bottom of the strike zone but again with
not the same sinking action that
you would think that fleming has had for
some of
to his games it's five nothing texas
phillips and second at bat of the ball
game he flew out to center field in the
third here's the payoff pitch
strike three call and down goes phillips
well there has not been a walk in this
game for either side and there are
runners at first and third now and one
out
well here comes chris woodward he's
going to call to the bullpen after
talking to gibson
for a few moments he decided to signal
for john king
and we'll see if john king can strand
the runners here
he's now out for his last 14 with that
strikeout
king gets him for the second out of the
inning meadows
is old for two today he's grounded out
and struck out the pitch to meadows that
one
in the air out to left field calhoun
right there for it and the inning is
done
and the rays leave them at first and
third we go to the eighth it's still
five nothing texas
with a base hit to begin the inning one
on one out we'll go back to the top of
the order
brandon lau this one's swung on and a
fly ball
well tagged and that one's going to get
out of here
home run into the texas bullpen brandon
lau
connects on a 2-2 pitch
and the rays get on the board to make it
5-2
home run number 10 for brandon lau
and we're heading for the ninth it's ian
kennedy time and the bases are gonna be
loaded with one out in the ninth inning
and they're bringing man walmart go to
the plate
0-2 pitch and that's in the air
short right field gallow in position
he'll make the catch
tagging at third meadows and he holds
and oh is that a wise call
a strike to the plate by joey gallo
and the razor down to the final out and
well the scheduled hitter has had some
heroics in this building before
so here's brad he's over three
and a line drive base hit into right
here comes meadows and to score
the rays will get two as kirbyer crosses
the plate
on the base hit by phillips and it's 5-4
so the rays aren't done yet brandon lau
comes to the plate
with a single and a two-run homer in his
last two
at bats 0-2
kennedy gets that final out and the
rangers take the opener 5-4
from the rays